happy like this we're on folks we are
live back on gamespot stage here at e3
2014 and we have a very special treat
for me personally here I've got a
control in my hand I'm gonna get to play
a video game on stage because Tim Rogers
from action button is here Casey Lynch
from midnight cities here it's video
vault so that's me right there that's
you on screen hey guys guys video ball
video ball yeah video balls the game I
do you call it a game because I I've
heard tell that you are claiming you are
asserting it as a sport it is definitely
a sport okay it is a sport it is I mean
as far as games go it has a your action
shooting strategy team-based multiplayer
metaphors or whatever sure yeah all the
all the button all the music boxes it is
certainly a sport we call it V game be
game that's and that's capitalized you
can hear it that's all capitalized yeah
a game or the game depending on where
you're putting the words of the game in
the sentence okay you would you would
emphasize a different word all right now
I are we gonna we gonna fire it up here
we're gonna get into a match well every
time I look at this title screen it's
like there's there's some fire happening
it's so it's really you got these
options you got local the low got the
online so do you see on the margin is
options that online option is actually
not a that's not an accident that a lie
that's not it's not a line it is not an
accident it's there for real you can
video ball online yes it's a promise I
mean why is why would you want to nut
and play video ball online why would you
I have no good reason say no in jail
yeah that's that's really all there is
to it all right so we've got local we've
got online can we choose maybe local
yeah we're going to choose local because
I mean I think online multiplayer is
great I think it's the best thing but
three sweet when you got a whole bunch
of people in a room and you want to play
a game we designed this to be played by
a whole bunch of people in a room in
addition to online that is the thing
that I'd love to do get every Monday
actually have a livestream multiple
players we get in a broom we all play
there's there's cheeky banter and the
agony of defeat seems like video ball is
a good fit yes alright which I um so how
do we want to do these teams I'm going
to go on the Left team
you're gonna be with him Vito's really
good this guy off stage he's so good at
video ball we cannot put him on camera
all right that's uh so I want to i'm
going to tell everybody know to sign in
just choose now no so okay seal entry
number three I did okay I'm ready i'm
going to send myself in what you're
right fine fine yeah I mean we manage
your paratus do it go to our school we
should have all fired up maybe we should
have all signed it no good have fun uh
this is not final you I uh you see you
got a couple different courses in the
works I'm going to put us on three balls
because that's more balls is more action
yeah I want to put us on music number
eight can people hear the music I don't
know they will be able to you will
probably not be able to the music is
tasty so if you tell everybody on to it
if you're if you're not hungry you want
to shut your computer off them because
you're gonna get a meal what this tune
I'm just going to start it up let's do
it this also is not final you I I just
want to keep saying that but uh anyway
to belay my electronics pork casual
enough to clean a Java birthday party
Harvard s televised in prison there's me
see me in the corner I see you lucky use
an analog stick to move yep and any one
of the face buttons to shoot so you want
to hold and then release and the longer
you hold the bigger the shot the bigger
the shot the harder it pushes the ball
killed right there and if you get hit by
the ball you get stunned you get still
as I have learned to my chagrin like
three times now if you get hit by a shot
you also gets done so notice you want to
look at the expanding circle in front of
your player right so you see it goes one
level one is I find a little tiny
triangle yeah level two fires this one
which will push the ball multiple times
yeah it'll stay on the field and level 3
if you let go on the third pulse will
get a slam shot or the same node is
that's the money this lady Davis jr. but
see i reversed it what so any slam shot
can be reversed by any shot now if you
charge up all the way to the fourth
level you will end up with one of these
which is a fly that will uh oh oh shut
it down yeah block my block did not come
in time yes so the IDS you to lift the
ball into the opponent's goal this is
not going well for team my team yeah
we're not gonna go easy on you clearly
if you want to win in video ball you
have to get to fight for it alright it's
got a solid shot on it for the first
time and so it's you're paying attention
to these flashes the sizes of the ball
right at the cone of your I'm sorry yes
that's pretty much the way better ears
right like is there's there's not really
any Jocelyn right what if I run into you
if you run into me uh we just kind of
get in each other's way we originally I
mean we've prototyped a lot of ideas
we've been balancing and tuning and
tweaking this game for about a year and
we've prototyped some ideas such as if
players run into each other they get
stunned so because uh wow we we just one
really hard well I'm sorry about that I
was vicious all right now it's getting
one bit again look listen you guys you
guys have been you know video ballin so
hard like I play this game like 12 hours
a day I'm not even I'm getting that's a
full-time job we're at making AI BOTS
right now so it's like oh my i have to
play the game a lot and watch a lot of
people play to understand what behaviors
to script for the AI so you're now you
basically turned yourself into a student
of human behavior in order to make this
happen yes and oh oh oh tonight i'm
putting on a big defensive plays here my
teammate Oh has dropped out just coming
away we've got these wireless
controllers here and play around the
Italian tutor is a with the dongle go
too far away if there's if there's any
place that you're no no betta I miss I
scored my first goal really my veto ball
professional veto is my teammate we lose
eat up he's a his controller freaked out
all right we gonna we're gonna bring it
back it's gonna be okay there we go
block oh yeah oh my god i really like
this game man this is good i'm actually
not doing terribly the side so hey you
don't know shoot me so what is the
benefit of the tiny ones why would you
always go for the law that well our shot
well so if a ball has been slammed if
it's been spiked at you uh you can just
use the tiny shot to reverse it or you
can use a tiny shot to snipe your
opponent to stun them for a little bit
so yeah you don't need you don't need
the momentum of a slam shot to counter a
slam shot know if it's been slammed it
can be Reese lammed or D slams Oh get
out of here i'm doing a moderate amount
of defense and goal scorer I probably
still get I realized how Roberto nice
idea thank you for letting that happen I
suspect maybe it looks like you're uh
you're getting pretty good at video ball
you know I some people take five or six
games to get pretty good at it mm-hmm
you said as I score an own goal or an
own touchdown or a known slam dunk what
exactly is the terminology for a score
here well show so I mean everything is
worth a point so every single are they
going to restart the game here every
every single score is worth one point
every slam dunk yes I am done for the
point of touchdowns appoint every hole
in one a home run as a point sure but so
for example a slam dunk is if you if the
ball spawns and you hit it with a slam
shot and you score it into the goal
without anyone else touching on obstruct
justice lamb it's like like an ace in
tennis basically so that's a slam dunk
yeah alright so the names correspond to
the method of scoring yes yeah just just
how you did it what if what if it's a I
scored by someone who's trying to clear
the zone slice smash it back right in
the face uh we're reversal that's well
that well if your image let's try to get
it out that's a rejection rejection we
have rejected with the opposite
that oh oh oh so you're ok telly on
offense and they're trying to clear it
now I was like nope goal that of
rejection I don't know what we call that
that's what ever thats a jam I'm sorry
that's a jam it's a jam if you can t see
and we even have the announcer say say
jams it in so and the word jam will play
who's our beloved announcer announcer is
Jen Frank who Jen Frank Twitter maven
yes all over Twitter uh-uh voice of
super hexagon voice of super hexagon
elliptic and write rent too many friends
too many friend of many are we gonna
play this again let's do this again
nobody is player 1 it is it is virtually
unpredictable press Start tis not I veto
oh it's you local alright so me and
Lynch you're gonna go left sign it to
sign in everybody just sign right on and
choose new to register a new name yeah
and I'm going to be me because I'm in
here already well are you just being AAA
what are you doing hey a big oh come on
how do i change it Oh up and down 04 c
14 yeah that's a code secret what does
that mean what does see one for me is
its secret okay listen are you going to
see you heavier developer mysteries i
have my host mysteries this is my
semester at all i have a three letter
name is ur blank uh no and there will be
a blank later this is not final you i
I'm sorry come on I love that font
though look at that God darn fun ready
to go there we go there is right down
the bottom all right Casey one alright
feat oh I'm feeling strong a few good
clean genetic pro yeah put it on be pro
well get in there put it on three balls
uh put the music temperature on just put
it back on the ocho it put it on eight
again we have like so much music in this
game that does it come from our composer
is a goes by the internet handle coda ha
co da uh you can find him on the band
camp and the soundcloud
he does justice really fantastic none
chiptunes gaming music it's chiptune
sorta but uh it's got this kind of what
do you call it sounds kind of like a
Genesis kind of like a super nintendo Oh
basic pro which as you can see is a
smaller arena oh no we just canceled our
shots out I so the goal is smaller it's
a tiny little baby goal yeah and a lot
of reversal sir yeah serious we're
getting we're getting some serious
triangle on ball action so we have
around 20 stages in the game better all
I think they all offer a I know this
sounds kind of like a jerky thing to say
but they're all a a slightly different
game you know with the same rules you
have to play very different strategies
to the sorrel digital I said he that my
teammate has done some sunblock d yeah
he's uh he's trying to be clever it's
what he's doing he's off of one of those
some little ideas some strategies but so
we've got uh some stages that have
obstacles in the middle of the field or
around the field yeah oh no way yeah I
really wanted to shut you out there I
know but you were stunned oh wow that
guy got in the way so you construct your
own your own like you can get in your
own way oh heck yeah yeah I got i block
my teammates bid there I've got to
respect your teammate you got to respect
yourself you know that's a that can be
challenging but some of the stages are
bigger than uh than this some of them
are much bigger than this what's the
ball limit I mean big kids as well
you're completely bonkers bottom limit
is infinity infinite that's yen so you
can actually have infinite balls which
is really stupid and really great it
seems excessive you can play with one
ball and that gives you more of your
classic NBA Jam NHL hockey experience
just what I wanted I wanted something
that was as good as an engine yeah I
mean ontogenesis Yoshi that no oh so
close Kate I know Oh your own your own
blocks are keeping you out of it Oh get
it get Oh what no get in crap
ah I scored I did it you also scored and
have scored wedding fav whale more all
right we're running we're running a long
time here guys oh I'll just win right
now we got to do some dramatic finishes
what what do you have in store what do
you have in store for what what do you
mean for you oh those things is gonna go
well for us I don't know I'm throwing in
the Hat Vito I've come back from bigger
deficit yeah that's a ghost video ball
uh Tim Casey when one can I video ball
went can t video ball I am when can I
video ball when's that coming out well
what systems are coming out for man I
want a video ball oh well it's
definitely coming out on the pc let me
tell you that yeah sure it's definitely
coming out on pc back I suppose linux if
you have one of those show me consoles
uh I don't know all right are there is
no sorry we do know it is going to go
since we haven't confirmed the block but
that's why we bring your case if you
have a game console at home chances are
you're gonna be able to play it on one
of those consoles you're probably gonna
have video ball about this year are we
gonna be up late it is gonna be this
year oh god yeah absolutely so it's not
this year I don't know what I'm going to
be our myself if it's not better bad
things can happen if it all right it
will hopefully be some time before major
holiday some cool well we're gonna have
to get you guys into the game spot
Studios play some video ball on multiple
players any time i'm in oakland
california now i live in berkeley we're
gonna make it happen thank you guys for
coming on set and you're ballin folks
we're gonna head out to lisa foiles with
some big III stuff out there and then
we'll come back here I'll see you soon